the jurogan experience um your book the
new book is rationality rationality what
it is why it seems scarce why it matters
it is
kind of scarce
it certainly seems scarce what has
happened to us well it's
i yeah i think that this is a lot of
rationality inequality
yeah you know at the top end we've never
been more rational right not only do we
have just mind-boggling technology
in terms of
mrna vaccines and
smartphones and 3d printing and
artificial intelligence but we have
rationality applied to areas of life
that formerly were just a matter of
of you know seat of the pants guess work
and hunches and and you rely on experts
so you have things like you know
moneyball where
some genius thought well if you make
decisions in sports like drafting and
strategy based on data instead of the
hunches of you know some old general
manager you could actually have an
advantage and so the oakland a's went
all the way with a fairly small
budget for players because they applied
data now every team has a statistician
data-driven policing one of the reasons
that the crime rate in the the u.s fell
by more than half in the 1990s it wasn't
that all of a sudden guns were taken off
the street it wasn't that you know
racism vanished or inequality vanished
part of it was that police got smarter
since a lot of violence happens in a few
small areas of a city often by a few you
know hotheads few perpetrators yeah if
you concentrate police on where the
crime hot spots are you can control a
lot of crime without that much manpower
we were just having evidence-based
medicine yeah you know evidence-based
policy and governance so there are areas
in which we've applied rationality in
areas that formerly were just
gut feelings and hunt and hunches i'll
give you one other example effective
altruism a movement that i'm kind of
loosely connected with
where do your charitable dollars save
the most lives
um should you buy malarial bed nets
should you buy seeing eye dogs for for
blind people
it makes a big difference and that's so
charity now is becoming more rational so
all these areas policing and sports and
charity and government are becoming more
rational but of course at the same time
you've got you know chemtrail conspiracy
theorists you've got the idea that
coveted vaccines are a way for building
gates to implant microchips in people's
uh
don't they make you magnetic
right
um what's interesting to me is that uh
there's
a thing that goes along with uh
irrational thought where you have
irrational thought that is confined to
your party lines right yes if you are
if i mean there's just a blanket
statement but if you are right wing you
are more likely to dismiss the worries
of climate change yeah absolutely in
fact that's the that is the main
predictor of whether you dismiss climate
change has nothing to do with scientific
literacy you know a lot of my fellow
scientists say oh the fact that there's
so much denial of man-made climate
change means we need you know better
science education in the schools we need
scientists becoming more popular
and and
making
the climate science more accessible
turns out that whether you accept
human-made climate change or not has
nothing to do with how much science you
know and a lot of the people who do
accept it know you know diddly about the
science they often will think well yeah
climate change isn't that because of you
know the the hole in the ozone layer and
toxic waste dumps and you know plastic
straws in the oceans right really a lot
of them are out to lunch
whereas
some of the climate deniers they're like
well-prepared litigators they can find
every loophole they know every study
they you know a good lawyer can argue
against anything
what does predict your acceptance of
climate change is just where you are on
the political spectrum the farther to
the right the more denial so abs that's
what you said is absolutely right it's
not just more denial but this
willingness to instantaneously argue it
like uh the the subject came up oddly
enough in jiu jitsu or after class we're
uh like just getting dressed and putting
stuff away and someone said man it's
just uh it's just a fact of life that
it's getting hotter every year and this
guy jumped in immediately with like this
defense
of
this idea that climate change is
nonsense and it's like listen it's a
cycle it's always been going on like
this and like how much research have you
done yeah like do you think you don't
think people affect it at all i'm like
yeah it is a cycle right if you go back
and look at core samples and you look at
the ice ages and you look at all the
various times in the history of the
earth the climate has moved we were
actually just talking about this
yesterday i had someone on who's an
expert in ancient
civilizations and all these
archaeological mysteries that they've
found and one of the things we were
talking about was the sahara desert that
the sahara desert goes through this
period of every like 20 000 years or so
where it's green and then it becomes a
desert again and then it becomes green
again and it goes back and forth and 5
000 plus years ago it was very green and
now it's a inhospitable desert and you
know this guy just like had this like
right wing talking point instead of
arguing with them i said how much
research have you done i'm like what do
you think is happening like well it's
just a cycle like it's definitely a
cycle but don't you think it's
extraordinary the amount of co2 we put
in the atmosphere yeah there can be
superimposed trends there can be a cycle
and on top of that it can be the forcing
that that we're doing it's both things
it's both clearly there's like the the
earth varies it has varied forever in
terms of like the climate shifting back
and forth but clearly
like if you look at
any like mexico city is a great example
i flew into mexico city once and i took
photos because i couldn't believe there
wasn't a fire i'm like i can't believe
this like when you live in los angeles
you're used to smoky skies when there's
forest fires and wildfires but mexico
city had there was no fire it was just
pollution like these poor [ __ ] people
they have to live in this [ __ ] every day
this is crazy
no that's true actually
what surprised me the most of all the
places i've been is uh africa tanzania
and uganda where there is a brown haze
everywhere and that's because people
burn wood and charcoal oh that's
something that people need to realize
well they heat up wood to make the
charcoal and the charcoal and there is a
haze over the landscape
uh with nothing like nothing i've seen
a lot of the worst
unhealthiest air pollution is people uh
cooking with open fires in their own
houses isn't that wild which is wild
you would never think that burning wood
outside would have a significant impact
on the environment but it really does
yeah i mean it isn't forcing climate
change it's a different kind of problem
right that's another problem it's a
different ground but yeah but going back
to what we're talking about
one of the big conclusions of
rationality is that a lot of what we
deplore now as you know just crazy uh
stuff conspiracy theories and the fake
news
a lot of it comes from one bias the my
side bias which you kind of already
alluded to namely you
you believe in the sacred uh beliefs of
your own clique your own political party
your own coalition your own tribe
your own sect
and you
paint the other side as stupid and evil
for having different beliefs there's a
perverse kind of rationality in being a
champion for your cause because you know
you get brownie points from all your
friends and if you were to
defy them if you were to to accept
climate change in a hardcore
right-wing circle you'd you know you'd
be a pariah you'd be yeah it would be
social death so there's a perverse kind
of rationality in
championing the beliefs of your side it
isn't so good for whole democracy when
everyone is just promoting the beliefs
that that
get them prestige within their own
coalition rather than the beliefs that
are actually true
yeah it's
it's strangely prevalent right like it's
so common that people have this ideology
they subscribe to the belief system that
is attached to that ideology and
whatever whether it's left wing or right
wing and they just adopt a
conglomeration of ideas instead of
having these things where they've
thought them through rationally and
really like looked at it instead they
they have an ideology and whether it's
left or right wing and it seems to me
it's
it's a real shame that we only have two
choices in this country politically like
if you look at holland if you look at
there's a lot of countries that have
many many choices and i think if we had
many many choices you would have you
still have tribalism but at least you'd
probably have a more varied idea of what
it is we have
very polarizing perspectives we have a
left and a right and each side thinks
the other side are morons and are
ruining the country absolutely there has
been a rise in negative polarization
yeah that is in the sense that the
people you disagree with uh aren't just
mistaken they don't just have a
different opinion but they are evil and
stupid so that has risen especially at
the extremes it's still true that a
majority of americans call themselves
moderate but the extremes hate each
other more and it's interesting you know
why that's happened it's you know the
common explanation is you blame it on
social media and people being in filter
bubbles you know that might be part of
it but part of it may also be
people segregate themselves in terms of
where they live more so you get kind of
educated
hipsters and knowledge workers in cities
and you get less educated people moving
out to the outer suburbs and rural are
staying in rural areas so people just
don't meet people who disagree with them
anymore who have come from different
backgrounds or less than they used to
and some of the ins organizations and
institutions that used to bring people
from different walks of life together
um
churches service organizations like you
know the elks the rotary club and so on
are declining so we tend to hang out
more with people like ourselves well
even in universities which used to be a
place where people on the left and
people on the right could debate
i mean in high schools even like i
remember when i was in high school
barney frank
debated someone from the moral majority
and i remember um
watching it i think i was 16 and we went
and sat and watched this debate and
watch barney frank trounce this guy and
mock him and it was pretty fun uh but it
was it was interesting because we got
this to hear two very different
perspectives but one at the at the time
barney frank who's just better at it and
had better points was more articulate
and had a better argument and we walked
away from that having heard both sides
and but having heard one side argued
more effectively and you don't get that
anymore instead now you get one side and
when someone tries to bring someone in
that as of a differing opinion to debate
this person that person gets silenced
they try pulling alarms and buildings
and they shout and blow blow horns and
call everyone a nazi and it's
unfortunate because you you miss the
opportunity like i got to see when i was
16 where i got to see a more
articulate
person with better points of view better
perspectives
argue more effectively that their
perspective was
was more rational yeah no i think that
that that's vital now
there is uh some evidence that people
who are have really hardcore beliefs
can't be talked out of them with any
amount of evidence some people yeah some
people but exactly so you know people
ask me as a question i get asked a lot
in uh when i talk about
rationality they say well how do you
convince a real q anon believer that
there isn't a cabal of of uh satan
worshiping cannibalistic pedophiles in
the the democratic party and and
hollywood and the basement of a pizza
house and the basement of comet ping
pong pizzeria you know the answer might
be for some of them you can't it's kind
of like the question how do you convince
the pope that jesus was not the son of
god well
you you can't i mean some people will go
to their grave believing what they
believe but you don't have to convince
everyone there are people who are not so
committed they might you know they may
find a little plausible and but their
identity isn't fused with it it doesn't
define who they are and they might be
open to argument and of course new new
babies are being born
all the time and they aren't born
believing in in q anon or chemtrails or
9 11 truther
theories
and some of them can be peeled off by by
rational arguments i think it's not
tried enough including
in
issues that i strongly believe in like
human-made climate change like safety
and efficacy of vaccines and on and on i
think that scientists and public health
officials have not been
willing enough to show their work
they've just
set themselves up as priests
and as said people believe me i'm a
scientist well that's like could not be
farther from the way science works the
whole point of science is there is no
authority you've got to show the goods
it's data you always might be wrong
uh and what made
what kind of increased my confidence say
in human-made climate change
20 25 years ago i was you know a little
bit open to it but then
seeing the objections like it's all just
cycles or it's just because the
temperature measurements were
[Music]
the cities grew and so the weather
monitoring stations were used to be out
in the country now they're in the city
and cities are hotter that's you know i
actually heard this from a nobel prize
winner but seeing the counter arguments
where there's a site called skeptical
science where they take on every one of
the
objections to human-made climate change
and they explain why
why it's uh unlikely to be true i find
that fantastically convincing and and i
think that
um that we should not give up on
people's ability to
to to uh take in evidence seriously this
granted there's some people who won't
you know
that people we all
to some extent act like lawyers we argue
a cause
if there's a counter argument we try to
we rack our brains to figure out how we
can you know refute the counter argument
so there is that especially when the
belief is close to your personal
identity
that's not true of all beliefs for
everyone and
public health officials government
officials scientists should be prepared
to show their work this is why i believe
it not just this is the truth